battle is about to commence between five
home Cooks but only one can win a
thousand dollars and the title of
culinary genius
[Applause]
[Music]
hello I'm Samantha Harris and welcome to
culinary genius today's Cooks Face two
high pressure battles and later
Superstar Chef Gordon Ramsey will be on
hand to give them some inspiration now
today's contenders have each brought an
item from home which they hope will help
them compete now providing quality
control is a fantastic chef from the
south Edward Lee
hello hello
are expecting from these fantastic
hopefully Cooks we have here today we
have a tough fish prep challenge for the
three survivors who make it to the final
cook-off I have a Super Fresh Pantry of
Asian Mediterranean and Tex-Mex inspired
ingredients well in round one our
contestants will have their filleting
skills put to the test and at the end of
the battle two will be heading home so
let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants please lift your cloches
it's salmon
before Edward sets the first challenge
here is legendary Chef Gordon Ramsay on
how to get the best from this king of
oily fish
right today you're getting to work with
this beauty this is the king of the sea
incredible fresh wild salmon now whether
you're poaching grilling trust me is
incredibly delicious it's healthy it's
packed with protein and omega-3 now when
buying fresh salmon make sure the flesh
is firm the eyes and the gills are
bright what would I do with this today
I'd turn this into the most amazing hot
smoked salmon serves over a bed of warm
potato salad so Edward what's the first
challenge for our talented Cooks today
thanks Gordon today Cooks I want you to
fillet a whole salmon into 10 equal
portions so the first thing I do is I
take that first fin I'm going to go
behind that collar and I'm going to make
a small incision lift the fin
go right under there
always move the fish towards your hand
don't move your hand towards the fish
what I'm going to do is take this knife
and just the tip of the knife goes in
and we're going to follow that bone okay
now peel back
the flesh a little bit and we're going
to run that knife
along the bone here
angle that knife just a tiny bit down
what you're trying to do is leave as
little Flesh on the bone as possible
opens right up
okay now I want to release that I'm
going to come right back this way turn
my fish back and I can take my boning
knife at this point and and just come
right across here just a very gentle
sawing motion
when you get to the tail just clip it
right off boom
your fish should release perfectly right
off there we're going to go for the next
side right so you're going to take your
knife you're going to go underneath the
meat is staying on the fillet not on the
bone
very good now we're gonna start cleaning
this fish so you want to make a nice
beautiful shape
trim that out
I want five even pieces out of here one
two three four
and the last piece five
if I were to put this on a scale they
should all weigh the same amount back to
your stations let's do this
at the ready
let the battle begin
[Music]
fling does not look easy but why is it a
good thing to do the key thing is
freshness that is the most important
thing about fish if you buy a whole fish
you know all those gorgeous nutrients
and all that flavor is still in there
fillet yourself and you're guaranteed a
fresh piece of fish all right well let's
see how they're doing on the floor
how do you feel you're doing so far
a little bit oh
listen give her some support at the
beginning delicate yes right this is not
a piece of meat go with small incisions
because if you make a mistake you can
always recover well yeah hopefully I'm
doing okay
how is the knife skills going there very
interesting okay very interesting you
keep twisting that fish back and forth
yeah you're making the fish
you're manhandling that Fish Market are
you feeling confident with it at the
moment not really listen most important
thing I need fillets on that board do it
however way you need to okay all righty
all right how you doing I'm doing all
right okay good smiling you see you seem
positive and you have a chubby Cherry
sauce here would that do you feel go
nicely with this if you make it through
the next round I think it would yeah a
good marinade for the fish listen you're
doing a pretty good job okay keep it
going nice surgical we're at the halfway
mark Cooks the halfway mark hello javar
hello you're manhandling that salmon a
little bit and poor salmon it's okay
it's okay yeah don't hate me too much
I'm sorry because I see a lot of Flesh
on those bones so I want to see them
beautiful and let's go
all right Suzanne how are you finding
the challenge uh challenging you're
telling me good have you ever done this
before uh never never for someone who's
never done it before you've got one
fillet down
I think everyone's having a little bit
of difficulty with this fish
yeah everyone's kind of going in there
and and they're just kind of sawing at
the fish I think Eileen is uh was just a
little bit tentative and she needs to
just be confident and just make nice
swooping simple small incisions all
right how about Mark I know he was
flipping it over and over again Mark
needs to stop dancing around with the
fish keep it on the cutting board and
start filleting it he's got a pretty
good start he just needs to keep on
going you know what Magnum is doing
pretty good she had that first filet
down she's cutting it nice and smooth it
looks beautiful she's going very slowly
so I just want to make sure she has
enough time to finish one final minute
to go javar is working quickly but a
little bit messy so I want to make sure
that fish is really nice you know
Suzanne hopefully was really tiny it's
about keeping the Flesh on the fish not
on the bones just get it on that one
nine eight seven six
knives down
so who salmon has kept them in the
competition come back and find out right
after the break
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
contestants have attempted to impress
Edward with their filetting skills but
only three can make it through to the
final round
let's go ahead and start with you Eileen
I think you ran out of time with these
guys and you're kind of messed up over
here these five are absolutely gorgeous
my goodness your salmon looks like it
got into a fight with a shark your meat
over here is just looking like chopped
liver
have you done this before not on a fish
this big okay so that was big change
really nice really nice oh look at that
perfect
this is fish you can work with you just
needed to trim them off better a little
bit of time yeah yeah it's not bad it's
a little bit sloppy and you need more
time to just make it pretty but the
essentials you kind of got so not bad
thank you you got your fish on the board
however you only have eight Suzanne I
could feed a family of four with the
fish that you left on this bone okay all
right you know it's a tough first round
indeed but now it is time for Edward of
course to tell us who has made it
through to the cook-off
[Music]
the first contestant going through to
the final is
[Applause]
[Music]
the second contestant to go through is
Eileen
[Music]
third and final contestant to go through
to the cook-off is
Java
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well congratulations Maggie
Eileen and Jafar you are going through
to the finals that means of course we
have to say goodbye to Mark and Suzanne
so thank you for being a fun part of
today's show
our three finalists must now produce a
dish of the highest quality using the
salmon that they have already prepared
so Chef what are you looking for from
our three finalists you have to be more
creative than the person standing next
to you make sure the presentation is
delicious and pretty to look at now you
have just two minutes to grab as many
ingredients as you want the time starts
now
Chef what do we have in the pantry today
we have everything from fennel to
Watercress we have edamame beans there's
lemongrass in there beautiful lemongrass
there's juniper berries you can do
things with miso pine nuts maple syrup
and even tequila oh I see some stuff
that I start grabbing and I had two
different directions I was going to go
but I just kind of just grabbed
everything just one minute left we're
halfway through one minute left
contestants there's so many good
ingredients automatically my brain just
had an overload of ideas on what to make
remember this is your one trip to the
pantry get everything you need
five four three two one step away from
the pantry don't grab anything else time
is off the pantry is closed now you have
25 minutes to create a PS2 resistance
that could lead you to culinary Glory so
let the battle begin
hello Eileen we're stepping in to find
out what you grabbed for the pantry I'm
on the roast some Tomatoes
um I'm making some couscous I'm gonna
make a fennel salad to go with it I'm
Gonna Bake the salmon all right and lots
and lots of vegetable options are using
any others
um maybe some asparagus and maybe an
edamame puree as well I have a lot of
ingredients and I have to distribute
Maggie what did you grab I grabbed a lot
of different veggies and citrus fruits
so I'm gonna be marinating the salmon in
the chimichurri wow did you make this at
home it did yeah wow we made it up here
it smells I even grew the herbs yeah oh
my goodness
good luck Jabar salmon and you not a
pairing that you usually see nope not at
all not at all you don't cook with fish
no absolutely not why not why not what's
wrong with fish I've grown up I've never
liked Seafoods wow Yep this is my first
time I've ever cooked a fish like I had
nightmares that would be the main
ingredient but I mean flavors are
flavors so I can try to just do the best
I can do what did you grab from our
pantry well I grabbed a maple syrup
um some wine up some chilies mushrooms
and grits and couscous as well I saw
grits which I love to cook with so I'm a
southern boy my family's from originally
from Mississippi so okay
um I don't know just go back to my
Southern Heritage I guess and do this uh
do something with the Grits I have faith
in you Chef gorgeous Pantry options
today what would you have chosen and
what would you make all right so I see
some Shadow mushrooms some Tomatoes
beautiful Char all those vegetables
roast them on the side get that skin
really crispy and then really nice
butter fennel lots of lemon lots of
citrus pour that right over the fish
beautiful
Maggie is making a chimichurri marinated
salmon that chimichurri she brought from
home what I'm worried about with Maggie
is that I don't want that salmon
overcooked the worst thing is like
overcooked salmon with chimichurri javar
has never cooked salmon in his life now
he's going to prep a spicy salmon with
grits
and roasted vegetables trying something
for the first time especially under this
kind of pressure it can lead to mistakes
however javar's from the south I'm from
the south you put anything with grits
and some spice on it it's gonna be good
Eileen is making a Mediterranean style
baked salmon she's got a ton of
ingredients on her board she might get a
little confused
we're at 15 minutes Cooks 15 minutes
remain our finalists are doing their
utmost to claim the prize and of course
the title culinary genius it's all going
to be decided soon so make sure you come
back right after the break
[Music]
welcome back we are halfway through the
final battle three salmon are being
prepped and garnished as our contestants
go flat out to finish their dishes now
Maggie yes you've had a wonderful
opportunity to really travel around the
world how much has that influenced your
cooking style everywhere you go you try
new Incredible food so it kind of comes
out when you when you're cooking and who
do you usually cook for for my husband
and my family and I have a dog as well
and I cook biscuits for him
that is one lucky dog what it mean to
you to be able to win the title of
culinary genius it means I can probably
travel a little bit more well you
continue on a great start to your meal I
can't wait to thank you thanks
hello Eileen hi tell me a little bit
about your heritage and your cooking
style we actually cook a lot of
Cantonese food at home but growing up we
also had avocado with our Foods because
my dad's one of its first jobs was a
Mexican Chef in Canada oh it's really
eclectic my cooking style a lot of
different kind of flavors and you have
some of your family in the audience
today who's here for you my sister's in
the audience what is your favorite dish
that she makes Chinese steamed buns with
roast pork in it so that was delicious
delicious well I'm going to lead you to
it keep going thank you good start
cooked seven minutes remain
he's really putting in that much sugar
in his grits that's not gonna work at
all javar tell me a little bit about
growing up with soul food both my
grandmothers were Cooks uh cooking from
Mississippi so I learned watching them
growing up in the kitchen maple syrup
and the Grits don't judge me
never I would never was the beneficiary
of all these Good Eats that you're
making in the kitchen my husband of
three years he's I get to cook for him
because he burns water so oh no do you
really burn water I am like a horrendous
cook so how lucky do you feel that you
have javar who can actually cook a
fantastic meal in your home it's
incredible he would starve otherwise
being named culinary genius yeah what
would that mean to you
um I mean I've been clicking my brother
is a chef actually oh wow once he
graduated culinary school he went to the
Army and decided to serve the U.S this
is something that I know his dream to do
something like this and I'm here living
his dream for him it'll mean a lot to me
so this is for your brother yeah
absolutely all right well good luck
thank you
five minutes left we have five minutes
all right Maggie whoa so you love the
color green don't you I do okay green
green green green green Green is this
your salmon it is okay wow cool I'm
concerned about the salmon just because
there was so much going on um I think a
few pieces of my salmon got quite burnt
everything can be delicious but if your
salmon is not guess what you're
absolutely okay good luck thank you
to come what's going on I need to see
some energy what's going on you think
you're so confident I'm not you're so
confident you're going to win this that
you don't even have to break a sweat no
that's not true I'm actually freaking
out inside 25 minutes not a lot of time
to cook a dish how are you cooking your
salmon it's in the oven right now did
you pick the best fillets I did okay did
you make an extra one just in case
all right listen two minutes left
everyone beautiful plates think about it
are you tasting things as you go you've
never cooked salmon before so taste it
make sure you have the perfect thing I
tasted them flavors seem to be there
hopefully they work well together all
right we'll see you in a little bit
what do you think about Maggie Maggie's
food looks vibrant and she's got some
beautiful chimichurri some beautiful
vegetables going so everything's gonna
rest on that salmon fillet I'm gonna
have some wonderfully spicy salmon from
javar he knows what he's doing he's
confident if he can pull it off man it'd
be great 30 seconds just 30 seconds
think artistic
ten nine eight seven six
five four three two one step away from
your workbenches time is up
join us after the break to find out who
is today's Victorious cook
[Applause]
welcome back to the final part of
culinary genius where it is time for
Edward to judge our Cooks salmon
creations
I think that I've done as much as I
could I'm really hoping that Chef Lee
loves it
it's what I wanted it to be it looks
vibrant I think that the chimichurri
will really stand out so I'm really
happy with it
I feel confident in the flavors I don't
know about the presentation
what I love about this plant it's
refined it's elegant it's delicate but
that salmon is puny all your sides are
kind of overcrowding this really
delicate piece of salmon
it's a little bit overcooked okay okay
you got a lot of flavors going on in
this plate salmon is really delicate the
fennel salad with the orange is
beautiful couscous nice the asparagus
works that tomato it just kind of
overpowers the fish overall though I'm
really impressed this was a beautiful
plate of food
thank you
I love the vibrant colors I love the
flavors I love the green going on here I
love that chimichurri sort of around the
side very nice looking place you
seriously charred that salmon which
is good because you want that crispy
salmon skin but you also want that
beautiful Flesh on the bottom okay
well you managed to cook a nice piece of
salmon I know you use the chimichurri on
this you could have put even more on
there well done I would eat that any day
at a restaurant
foreign
look at this Balancing Act of asparagus
huh that's pretty cool all right
um
this is sassy
Chef would you like some water what am I
tasting that's like candy what you put
in those grits a little butter a little
sugar and just a touch of maple syrup I
feel like you put a lot of sugar in
there yeah I was trying to bounce the
spiciness with the sweetness spicy and
sweet aren't going to balance each other
out okay they're gonna sort of magnify
each other this is the first time you
cook salmon yeah all right I'm gonna
tell you that salmon is delicious it's
really really well done love the hit of
spice on there your salmon is delicious
everything else is kind of atrocious
so you have this thing where I was
expecting the salmon to suck but it's
gorgeous and I was expecting the Grits
to be delicious and it's not you
shouldn't be proud that salmon is
delicious listen for first time I'll
take it all right
all right our three finalists have
really given it their all and Edward has
decided on who impressed him the very
most
foreign
please lift your cloches
culinary genius is Maggie
congratulations
congratulations that dish
it screams summer it's vibrant
congratulations it was a beautiful
business
[Applause]
contestants now the leftovers will be
going to our local charity and we will
be back soon with five new contestants
ready to do battle for the title
culinary genius
[Music]